in the early hours this place is a hive
of activity birmingham's wholesale food
market supplying the city's supermarket
shops and restaurants
their wares may differ but there's a
challenge they share inflation's making
trading tougher
prawns which have gone up about 25 since
last year yeah
place has gone up about 10 percent
steven's price increases might sound
steep but so are the costs of getting
the fish here
you think the price of fish feed the
price of the packaging the price of the
ice to put on it
the price to go and harvest it with a
boat
the price to fill up some of these
fishing boats is astronomical if they're
big boats tens of thousands of pounds
it all means food inflation is rocketing
the overall rate a new 40-year high
and a key cause is this outside the
market the trucks used to transport it
unusually mark hasn't seen price rises
from his farmers for him it's all come
from the fuel
we're getting all the produce from all
over the world we've got indian grapes
here south african pairs the transport's
obviously gone up a lot with the fuel
problems um but we've still be able to
get the transport here
we try to not pass the prices onto the
end user the customers and the public
and we've just absorbed it a little bit
there the worry is that wages just
aren't keeping up a whole swathe of
strikes are threatened there's a sense
people are angry
the brutal fact is that the key drivers
of inflation are the very things that
people simply can't avoid buying things
like food like energy and like fuel and
that is what heaps pressure on both the
politicians and the bank of england more
significant rises to interest rates
could well be coming and while that
might help in the long run it will mean
more short-term pain for many
many causes are global of course but
other issues are more unique to here
including a shortage of staff this steel
fabricator has seen its raw materials
rise 150 percent it's worried about its
energy bills and it has vacancies to
fill the minute you're pricing one day
and then repricing two three days after
the same job it's it's that it's
fluctuating that much at the moment uh
trying to get new staff is is difficult
um
people just don't want to do it or
they're looking for ridiculous wages
there is no easy way out of this now if
wages rise too much that could make
inflation worse it will be tough to
maneuver helen and smith sky news
birmingham